and it reminds me of the experience i
had when i
you know was first buying homes and i
just became so resentful and angry
about being worked by real estate
brokers
where they i felt so manipulated and
i realized wait a second they work with
each other all day to just get a deal
closed
it doesn't matter if i buy this home for
a million
it doesn't matter to them a million a
million two 900k
doesn't matter matters to me but it
doesn't matter to them because six
percent of 900 or six percent of 1.2
is basically the same thing they just
want that fee and that's what they're
doing here isn't it
it's it's so funny to use that analogy
because my partner in crime on all this
has been rich barton
right from zillow who's gonna come on
the pockets you know you gotta put a
word in with rich i've been asking him
he sends me to his pr people the people
that you're gonna
give me four other executives and i'm
like no
he is one of the world's great founders
one of the great product thinkers one of
the great marketers
when we started talking about this 18
months ago
you know in the case of online travel
which is where
rich and i and frankly dara all met back
in 1999 2000 dora from uber
dara who's now running uber who at the
at the time was the head of mna for
barry diller
and he bought rich's company and my
company that's how we all met
in 2001 okay and back then if you wanted
to book an airline ticket there was a
monopoly called an airline reservation
system a gds a global distribution
system and the
and the monopolist in that case was
folks like saber
and if you want to book a ticket on
united it had to go through
their proprietary reservation system and
so not surprisingly they charged 20
bucks a ticket
right when when expedia and orbit showed
up they said well we don't need to go
through you we can build a direct
connect
we can build an api directly to united
airlines or american airlines yeah
they're not that many airlines
right and we can reduce the cost to a
dollar a ticket not 20
a ticket well lo and behold when you
drove competition into the market
what do you think happened to the price
of a gds it went down by 75 percent
right when you think about real estate
when rich called me we led the series b
and zillow and i went on the board um
you know j-hope bill gurley incredible
group around that
you know greg around that around that
table
and we said we need an api like we did
in the case of saber because the mls you
know rich calls this power to the people
right don't you remember like what
frustrates us with travel agents and
real estate agents back in the day is
they were looking at the green screen
and we just wanted to see what they were
looking at yeah just show it to us and
just control the data bloomberg
terminals whatever and so the idea
in the case of zillow was like the
unfortunate thing is there was no api
it wasn't your because it was fragmented
right and so it took them the stroke of
brilliance by lloyd and rich was this
estimate we can crowdsource an api well
that was
the zestimate was very controversial
explain to me the moment
when the zestimate was suggested in the
board and the controversy because
somebody brings that up and says i'm
gonna put a price on this home
and we're gonna make an estimate and
that is gonna tweak
the homeowner and if we're too high
too low whatever it's going to cost
chaos that was a bold move was it not
well it was it was a stroke of genius
that predated me actually
i you know i talked to lloyd and rich
early on what are you going to do after
expedia
and you know they had a very simple
thing like we discovered power to the
people turning the green screen around
so let's go find another trillion dollar
industry
where we can turn the screen around but
the idea
you know originally was like well buy
and sell homes like how do we
create the expedia effectively for real
estate the problem was
the realtors had the information and so
they had to discover how to get the
information i think it was lloyd
actually
remember back in the day jason like
mashups with google maps were all the
rage
yes okay and so i think it was lloyd who
had this idea what if we mashed up
mortgage pricing data with a google map
and we put a price on the roof of every
home in america
that would get everybody's attention
sure right uh
but you know let's you know the the
analogy and the reason we bring it up is
because
they now 15 years later and open doors
doing the same and eric and chamath are
you know doing a great effort there
they're trying to drive down the cost of
buying and selling a home
leveraging that information uh
democratization
okay and they're doing it so when you
look at a traditional ipo
you know a traditional ipo there's an
upfront cash cost to all the companies
and as bill would argue there's a big
indirect cost in the form of structural
enterprising
so i'm just a big believer in choice i'm
a big believer in competition